es un francotirador escondido en un
edificio de backmud solo lo acompaña su
arma
el objetivo ruso está 1,2 km de
distancia
se prepara para otra misión está a punto
de salir con sus hombres a patrullar la
zona en una operación de reconocimiento
avanzan hacia donde se escuchan las
explosiones de los proyectiles la
situación se ha vuelto más tensa en los
últimos días el centro de backmud es
ahora una ciudad fantasma
su misión es delicada y peligrosa el
pelotón de reconocimiento debe rastrear
objetivos rusos para informar a las
tropas ucranianas que están más atrás el
panorama es confuso
refugiado unas horas después de su
operación el ex legionario que pasó
cinco años en Francia explica la
situación militar Hablamos
ahora mismo diría que al menos el 50% de
la ciudad está tomada por los rusos
su avance continua
el consumidor
la situación es muy dura muy complicada
los ataques y asaltos rusos continúan
constantemente continúan los ataques los
disparos de todos los calibres
pero las fuerzas ucranianas siguen
resistiendo nuestro equipo pudo visitar
una de sus posiciones de artillería A
las afueras de backmuto Caminando un
kilómetro por rutas alternas para llegar
aquí y evitando espacios abiertos ambos
bandos disparan proyectiles
alguna de nuestras fuerzas siguen en el
centro de la ciudad
hemos venido a reconquistar nuestra
tierra no entregarnos
están esperando las coordenadas de un
nuevo objetivo después de intercambiar
disparos todo el día siguen atentos para
la contraofensiva desde hace semanas y
esperan que los suministros de armas y
equipos sean suficientes